volevo volevo iniziare con questa frase
la storia dell'astronomia è una storia
di orizzonti che arretrano la frase l'ha
detta edwin hubble che è stato uno dei
più grandi astronomi di tutti i tempi
quando edwin hubble
nel 1919 è arrivato a mount wilson in
california dove all'epoca c'era il più
grande telescopio più potente telescopio
esistente al mondo
non si sapeva se la nostra via lattea la
nostra galassia fosse tutto quello che
c'era nell'universo o se ci fosse anche
dell'altro fuori dall'area lattea si
riuscivano a vedere delle macchioline
indistinte di luce telescopi più potenti
delle nebulose non si sapeva cosa
fossero appunto c'era chi pensava che
fossero degli sbuffi di materiale
interni alla nostra da latte c'era chi
pensava che fossero a loro volta delle
altre galassie come la nostra via lattea
un insieme di centinaia di miliardi di
stelle che quindi dovevano essere
lontanissime per essere viste così
piccole dai telescopi più potenti hubble
fu il primo nel 1924 che riuscì a
misurare la distanza di una di queste
galassie la galassia m31 in andromeda
noi oggi sappiamo che una galassia la
vediamo così ma all'epoca non si sapeva
che fosse una galassia a misura la
distanza misura che la luce aveva
impiegato due milioni e mezzo di anni
per coprire la distanza che c'era da
quell'oggetto fino a noi aveva viaggiato
così tanto perché era un oggetto
lontanissimo e sarà un oggetto
lontanissimo significa che non stava
nella nostra via lattea ma stava fuori
l'universo era diventato improvvisamente
un posto molto più grande di quanto si
fosse mai pensato orizzonti che
arretrano appunto e in fondo è iniziata
così è iniziato tutto quanto così questo
è l'universo ai tempi quattro secoli fa
circa quando prima che galileo per la
prima volta alzasse un cannocchiale
verso il cielo notturno era un universo
semplice c'era la terra che stava al
centro di tutto quanto c'erano i 5
pianeti che si potevano vedere a occhio
nudo più il sole più la luna
che ruotavano intorno alla terra e tutto
al punto girava intorno a noi comprese
le stelle che erano anche quelle erano
poker a quelle che si potevano vedere a
occhio nudo era sembravano tante ma in
realtà quando galileo per la prima volta
si fabbrica un cannocchiale da solo era
un maker galileo era un maker italiano
si fabbrica un cannocchiale da sole lo
punta verso il cielo notturno vede delle
cose che non vanno tanto d'accordo con
questa immagine semplice dell'universo
innanzitutto vede che giove per esempio
a dei satelliti a delle lune quindi se
qualcosa ruota intorno a un altro corpo
celeste forse non è vero che ruota tutto
intorno alla terra forse anche la terra
ruota intorno al sole e poi soprattutto
scopre un'altra cosa un altra cosa
stupefacente scopre che le stelle che si
potevano vedere prima a occhio nudo
prima di usare il cannocchiale erano
molto di meno di quelle che c'erano
veramente lui punto al cannocchiale
immediatamente vede che ci sono molte
più stelle di quante se ne potessero
vedere a occhio nudo
quindi ancora una volta orizzonti che
arretrano un universo che diventa più
grande perché abbiamo uno strumento
migliore per osservarlo ed è continuata
così quella quella storia che è iniziata
quattro secoli fa ha continuato a far
espandere i nostri orizzonti e volevo
mostrarvi un'immagine questa però prima
devo spiegarvela è un'immagine in cui
vedete dei puntini luminosi questa
l'immagine che è stata fatta da un
telescopio che porta il nome di edwin
hubble e sta nello spazio el hubble
space telescope il telescopio spaziale
hubble per capire come è stata fatta
questa immagine pensate a questo hubble
ha puntato una regione di cielo di cielo
piccolissima insignificante in cui
sembrava che non ci fosse nulla per
capire quanto è grande e pensate
immaginate di prendere un granello di
sabbia di tenerlo a questa distanza alla
distanza di un braccio dai vostri occhi
ecco la grandezza di questo granello di
sabbia corrisponde alla grandezza che
della regione di cielo osservata per
fare questa immagine e apparentemente
appunto non c'era niente all'inizio ma
quando hubble ha continuato a
raccogliere luce a formare un'immagine
si è formata sono emersi tutti questi
puntini luminosi decine di migliaia di
puntini luminosi e questo e gia
stupefacente ma la cosa più stupefacente
è che ognuno di questi puntini luminosi
non è una stella
è una galassia una galassia come la
nostra via lattea un insieme di
centinaia di miliardi di stelle e
siccome quella regione così piccola ed
insignificante ed è uguale a qualunque
altra regione di cielo
noi oggi sappiamo che esistono nella
nostra nel nostro universo dell'universo
osservabile centinaia di miliardi di
galassie con centinaia di miliardi di
stelle dell'universo è diventato
veramente un posto complesso ricchissimo
e pieno pieno di stelle e di galassie
ma la cosa impressionante è che quando
guardiamo lontano e quindi facciamo
arretrare spingiamo più in là i nostri
orizzonti nello spazio in realtà stiamo
guardando anche indietro nel tempo
perché la luce impiega appunto un certo
tempo per raggiungerci da lontano la
galassia andromeda era talmente lontana
che la luce aveva versato 2 milioni e
mezzo di anni per raggiungere il
telescopio che stava usando hubble ma
quando guardate un'immagine come questa
la luce ha viaggiato quasi per tutta
l'età dell'universo per miliardi di anni
alcune di queste galassie sono
antichissime hanno un'età che è di soli
100 200 milioni di anni dopo dopo il big
bang dopo l'inizio di tutto e siamo
stati ancora più bravi di così perché se
guardate quest altra immagine
questa è un'immagine ancora precedente
dello stato dell'universo ancora
precedente quando ancora non c'erano
nemmeno le stelle nemmeno le galassie
c'era soltanto un gas incandescente
questa l'immagine che ci mostra come era
l'universo circa 400.000 anni dopo il
big bang quando si stavano formando i
primi atomi di idrogeno
non c'era niente solo questo gas
incandescente per darvi un'idea come un
po se una persona di 80 anni guardasse
la propria foto quando era un neonato di
poche ore ecco per darvi un'idea delle
delle scale di tempo con cui abbiamo a
che fare insomma in questi quattro
secoli abbiamo continuato a far
allargare i nostri orizzonti a spingerli
sempre più indietro sia nello spazio che
nel tempo aumentare la quantità di cose
che abbiamo capito dell'universo e per
il futuro per il futuro continueremo a
fare lo stesso e continueremo a fare
quello che abbiamo sempre fatto
costruire telescopi più potenti di
decine di metri di diametro manderemo
satelliti nello spazio cercheremo di
raccogliere la luce che viene dalle
distanze più incredibile che possiamo
immaginare ma non solo a luce anche
segnali elettromagnetici che i nostri
occhi non possono vedere
e faremo cose e cercheremo di vedere
cose che non riusciamo a vedere per
esempio cercheremo di capire di che cosa
è fatto il 96 per cento dell'universo
oggi sappiamo che noi siamo fatti di
atomi
ma il resto dell'universo fatto solo per
il 4 per cento degli stessi atomi di cui
siamo fatti noi il 96 per cento è fatto
di materia oscura energia oscura di cui
non sappiamo niente che cercheremo di
capire in futuro cercheremo di guardare
più indietro ancora più indietro nel
tempo la storia dell'universo che una
storia di 13,8 miliardi di anni oggi la
conosciamo molto bene ma vogliamo
spingerci verso gli istanti iniziali e
capire veramente come iniziato tutto
quanto capire le prime frazioni di
secondo dell'evoluzione dell'universo
capire che cosa ha spinto l'universo a
espandersi e se lo spazio il tempo sono
iniziati col big bang oppure no e poi
non vogliamo guardare soltanto lontano
nello spazio nel tempo ma magari anche
più vicino però più in dettaglio provare
a capire per esempio se intorno alle
stelle della nostra galassia ci sono
altri pianeti oggi sappiamo che così ne
conosciamo migliaia e questa è una lista
dei pianeti che somigliano di più alla
nostra terra anche se ancora non ne
abbiamo trovato uno che sia così simile
da poterlo definire un gemello è da
sapere che potrebbe essere
potenzialmente abitabile se in futuro lo
faremo continueremo a guardare ancora
meglio per capire se magari su uno di
questi pianeti c è qualche forma di vita
e dunque questo fenomeno fisico che è
avvenuto sulla nostra terra e che per
ora pensiamo sia unico si è avvenuto
anche altrove nell'universo e perché
continueremo a fare tutto questo perché
siamo una specie che ha bisogno di
esplorare una specie che ama farsi
domande vuole capire quello che ha
intorno e in fondo si sa quando ci
chiediamo se la terra sta al centro di
tutto quanto oppure no quando ci
chiedevamo se la nostra galassia era
tutto quello che c'era un universo
oppure no e oggi che ci chiediamo se ci
sono altri pianeti che ospitano la vita
in fondo stiamo sempre facendoci la
stessa domanda stiamo cercando di capire
qual è il nostro posto nell'universo
eccolo qui il nostro posto nell'universo
questa è la nostra la nostra casa
nell'universo oggi sappiamo che non è al
centro dell'universo però in qualche
modo per noi è speciale perché l'unica
casa che abbiamo è l'unico pianeta che
sappiamo con certezza essere abitabile e
quindi dobbiamo cercare di fare di tutto
per tenerlo meglio possibile questa
questa casa e questo pianeta che abbiamo
ecco c'è chi pensa oggi che la scienza e
la tecnologia stiano minacciando il
pianeta che che siano una minaccia per
la sopravvivenza dell'umanità e per la
sopravvivenza del pianeta stesso
e magari vorrebbero in qualche modo che
che guardassimo indietro che guardassimo
al passato io penso esattamente il
contrario
voglio guardare al futuro e penso che se
c'è un futuro per noi se possiamo
costruirci un futuro migliore è proprio
perché ci piace capire come funzionano
le cose ci piace costruire gli strumenti
per migliorare il futuro insomma credo
che la chiave per il nostro futuro sia
nella scienza e nella tecnologia e
quindi se posso augurarmi qualcosa in
futuro oltre ovviamente a sperare che
continueremo a scoprire cose stupende
meravigliose sull'universo e che meno
persone sempre meno persone abbiano
paura della scienza che le nuove
generazioni capiscano che la scienza non
è una cosa che ci rende meno umani ma in
realtà è un'attività che è tra le più
umane che esistano la voglia di
domandarsi di capire le cose
è una delle attività più umane che che
esistano e che la scienza ci serve non
solo per il benessere materiale che ci
dà ma anche perché ci porta sempre di
più a espandere e allargare i nostri
orizzonti
grazie